in a recent video We examined the
scourge of fake history in the context
of academic John Esposito's claim that
five centuries of peaceful coexistence
elapsed before political events and an
imperial papal Power Play It's like a
tongue twister led to centuries long
series of so-called Holy Wars that
pitted Christendom against Islam and
left an enduring Legacy of
misunderstanding and
distrust we also saw that that claim is
pure bunk those five countries of
peaceful coexistence featured Muslims
conquering 34s of the Christian world
all of the Middle East greater Syria and
all the nations that it encompassed at
the time all of North Africa from Egypt
to Morocco all of Spain or nearly all of
Spain except for the Northwest Quadrant
where the Reconquista began that'll be
another video eventually and into France
um until it was finally stopped at one
century after Muhammad's death in 732 at
the Battle of Tours we also saw that all
those conquests featured the usual
atrocities thousands of Christians were
killed put to the sword many more were
enslaved churches were burned turned
into mosques and so forth and we also
saw that at least according to the
Islamic historiographical tradition that
was done all those attacks and conquests
and Slaughters and destruction of
churches in accordance with Islamic
teaching Esposito's reason for lying was
clear he wants to portray that whatever
Bad Blood exists between Muslims and
Christians is squarely the latter's
fault the Christians fault therefore
everything before the first Crusades
which featured Christians going into
Muslim territory at the time is
presented as peaceful peaceful
coexistence until of course the Imperial
papal power play led to the Holy Wars
and misunderstanding and distrust from
Muslims against Christians Etc now let's
look at another lie em from another
Authority a so-called historian of
religions and I speak of course of Karen
Armstrong among other honors and
accolades that she has received she's
the bestselling author of many books
including a history of God holy war
Islam and the battle for
God so she too must know her Islam yes
in a 2007 article that she wrote in
which I actually responded to way back
then in an nro article Link in
description if you're interested she
made the following assertion once again
pay attention especially to the opening
part of this
exerpt ever since the Crusades people in
the west have seen the prophet Muhammad
as a Sinister figure The Scholar monks
of Europe stigmatized Muhammad as a
cruel warlord who established the false
religion of Islam by the sword they also
with ill-concealed Envy berated him as a
leer and sexual pervert at a time when
the popes were attempting to impose
celibacy on The Reluctant
clergy in other words she's saying that
negative images of Muhammad began in
Europe just before and as a pretext for
the first crusade in reality of course
non-muslims Christians Chief among them
because they were the ones who were
conquered and lived under Islam saw
Muhammad as a Sinister figure and a
sexual pervert right from the start her
words not mind so let's do a quick
review according to the oldest parchment
that alludes to a warlike Prophet which
was written in
634 this is just a mere 2 years after
Muhammad's death in
632 it has a man asking a learned Jewish
scribe what he knows about quote the
prophet who has appeared among the
sarasin unquote the elderly man with
much groaning responded he is deceiving
for do prophets come with swords and
Chariot verily these events of today are
works of confusion you will discover
nothing true from the said Prophet
except ccept human Bloodshed Muhammad is
also mentioned in a few fragments a
Syriac fragment written in 634 as well
and it's not very legible but you can
Scholars and linguists have discerned
that it mentions the quote followers of
muhmed as killing and slaughtering and
enslaving thousands of people uh in
Galilee and Bethlehem and up to 10,000
in the vicinity of Damascus writing in
640 Thomas the preser writes quote there
was a battle which was probably aad in
634 between the Muslims and the Arabs of
Muhammad in Palestine 12 mil east of
Gaza the Romans fled some 4,000 poor
villagers of Palestine Christians were
killed there the Arabs of Muhammad
ravaged the whole region and even
climbed the mountain of mtin and killed
many monks there in the monasteries of
Kadar and Bata also in the 640s a Coptic
homy is apparently the earliest account
to associate the sarasin Invaders with
an albeit hypocritical piety it counsels
Christians to fast but quote not like
the sarasin who are oppressors who give
themselves up to prostitution Massacre
and lead into captivity the sons of men
saying we both fast and
pray writing around 650 John of Niko an
Egyptian said that the ishmaelite
Invaders and conquerors of Egypt which
was conquered in 640 so he's an
eyewitness were not just quote enemies
of God but adherence of the detestable
doctrine of that Beast Muhammad end
quote by the way all of these preceding
quotes if you're interested and want to
Source them yourself are from this book
seeing Islam as others sought a survey
and evaluation of Christian Jewish and
zorran writings on early Islam by
uh by Robert holand
now aside from those scattered
fragmented sentences which again portray
Muhammad and his followers in negative
terms it's really only towards the end
of the seventh and early 8th centuries
that the Christians mostly semetic
Christians of semetic origins in Syria
and Egypt started to really scrutinize
and have access to the Quran and other
Islamic scriptures and the result is
that the image of Muhammad went from bad
to worse the best representative of the
this is St John of Damascus who was born
around
676 uh which is a long time before the
first crusade in 1095 based on his
analysis of the Quran and other uh
Islamic scriptures that he was able to
access he lived in Damascus he's a
semetic person he reads Arabic he
concluded that only miracle that
Muhammad performed was to invade
Slaughter and enslave those who refuse
to submit to him which he called quote a
miracle that even common robbers and
Highway Bandits perform quote he also
said that the prophet put whatever words
best served his purpose in God's mouth
thus quote simulating Revelation in
order to justify his own sexual
Indulgence unquote he made his religion
appealing and Justified his own behavior
by easing the sexual mores of the Arabs
infusing the notion of obedience to God
with war to Eng grandizer
cus bizantinos who also had a copy of
the Quran presented it as quote the most
pitiful and most inept little book of
the Arab Muhammad full of blasphemies
against the most high with all its ugly
and vulgar filth particularly its claim
that heaven amounted to a sexual
brothel in his entry for the years 629
630 theophanes the Confessor and Eastern
Roman chronicler or Byzantine as they
call it born in 758 wrote and this is a
good quote pay attention he Muhammad
taught his subjects that he who kills an
enemy or is killed by an enemy goes to
paradise and he said that this paradise
was one of carnal eating and drinking
and intercourse with women and had a
river of wine honey and milk and that
the women were not like the ones down
here but different ones and that the
Intercourse was long lasting and the
pleasure continuous and other things
full of pracy and
stupidity now notice this is actually
all direct from Islamic teaching and
Doctrine and the Quran he mentions how
Muhammad taught people that he who kills
the enemy and kills himself enters
Paradise well yeah check out Quran
9111 that's exactly what it says he who
slays and is slayed for Allah gains
Paradise as for the women that he's
discussing and how uh Paradise is
essentially a brothel well he's
referring to the Anor or the huris who
in Islamic teaching are essentially
Supernatural Celestial women created for
the express purpose of gratifying
Allah's favorites in
perpetuity the the suicide bombers
essentially perhaps most importantly for
Christians Muhammad's denial of and War
on all things distinctly Christian the
sunship of Jesus Christ the Trinity the
resurrection even the cross prove that
Muhammad was Satan's
minion thus the false prophet the
hypocrite the liar the adulterer the
Forerunner of antichrist and the Beast
were Main extreme epithets for Muhammad
amongst Christians for about four
centuries before the first crusade in
short it wasn't only right before and as
a pretext for the First Crusade that
Christians began to falsely demonize
Muhammad as a lecture and sexual pervert
and a cruel warlord her words Karen
Armstrong's not mine that is exactly how
they saw him right from the get-go
incidentally Armstrong's claimed that
the scholar monks of Europe quote with
ill-concealed Envy bered him Muhammad as
a lecher and sexual pervert at a time
when the popes were attempting to impose
celibacy on The Reluctant cler clergy
unquote seems to be a bit of projection
on Armstrong's part remember she's an
ex-nun who essentially betrayed her vows
oh perhaps it's her who is with quote
illc concealed Envy unquote who's taking
it out on her former colleagues who
stayed the course be that as it may let
us close by considering the lies of
Karen Armstrong in comparison to John
Esposito's although Muslims engaged in
violence and Conquest for five centuries
before the first crusade John Esposito
would have us believe that Christians
and Muslims lived in peaceful
coexistence for those five centuries and
although Christians have always seen
Muhammad as a Sinister figure Armstrong
claims that this view was fabricated
right before and as a pretext for the
first crusade in both cases everything
is once again and those evil Crusaders
fault